Before We Say Goodbye we like to play a  quick round of Truth or Dare  you get to ask me anything or Dare me to  do anything and I go there so Chloe here  you are how are you today I'm great how  are you you look lovely thank you you're  welcome truth or dare dare do it what do  I do so I've had a really old voicemail  for my whole life and I dare you to  record my voicemail for me  I would be honored too okay give me your  phone okay  um okay  hi this is Drew Barrymore I'm recording  the outgoing message for Chloe's inbox  please leave a message but also remember  to have a wonderful day thank you so  much  [Applause]  oh gosh thank you Chloe  [Applause]